Now, could you talk a little bit about
sort of how we go from adversarial
mindset to beating diversity and
thinking about how to exploit
the humans at the other end?
>> Well, I think what our adversaries do
And you want an adversarial mindset so
you can for this thinking and look for
these vulnerabilities
before someone else does.
I think typically what they'll do is
they'll probe the perimeter of a system.
Looking for vulnerability.
And it's really on multiple layers.
You can think of the technical layer,
and if the system is secure technically,
which is a very rare thing, but
let's assume that's the case.
Or maybe if they decided the amount
of work, the work factor involved
to bypass something technically
just too expensive in some ways.
Then they'll go looking for the ever
present weak link, which is the human,
and often times by
studying the given users
Finding their weaknesses themselves,
their personal vulnerabilities.
Those can then be exploited.
So I tend to think against
well-resourced and motivated adversary,
that the adversary will always
prevail given enough time and
resources to put into it